thierry solère députés les républicains
de boulogne-billancourt dans les
hauts-de-seine est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir je rappelle que vous êtes
également chargé de l'organisation de la
primaire de votre parti et du centre ce
sera en 2016
merci donc d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
comme chaque semaine trois parties et
trois grandes questions premièrement
françois hollande est il à la hauteur
des enjeux se révèle-t-il comme chef de
l'état 2 comme chef de guerre mondiale
également contre le groupe état
islamiste est actuellement le ca
washington et les toute la semaine vous
le savez de par le monde pour rencontrer
ses homologues des pays siégeant en
permanence au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu mme deuxième question qui a failli
puisque vous réclamer un audit sur les
services de sécurité et de renseignement
du pays mais les défaillances et les
faiblesses face à la radicalisation ne
concerne pas que les services mais aussi
des pans de la société
eh bien vous répondrai tout à l'heure à
perrine tarneaud de public sénat enfin
troisième question de l'émission thierry
solère pourquoi votre parti apparemment
votre parti des républicains semblent à
la peine à moins de deux semaines
maintenant du premier tour des élections
régionales et la cena des spiel jacques
de la fp qui vous le demandera
françois hollande donc se révèle t-il
comme chef de guerre selon vous il
annonce une série de mesures
sécuritaires d'ailleurs plébiscité par
l'opinion il multiplie les rencontres
avec ses plus grands homologues de la
planète pour une action efficace contre
le groupe etat islamique le chef de
l'état est il selon vous à la hauteur
des enjeux est d'avoir ces attentats ont
frappé tout le monde est bien sûr quand
il ya quelque chose de si graves qui se
passe en france on se tourner vers les
pouvoirs publics et le président de la
république au congrès a eu les mots
justes pour dénoncer ce qui se passait
et donne le sentiment de prendre la
mesure du problème
donc il est à la hauteur alors après mon
rôle à moi et être député d'opposition
s'est pas de vous sortir des petites
phrases pour vous dire des facilités
voyez un objectif à moi c'est que au
delà des prochaines échéances régionales
dans un mois enfin dans quinze jours
maintenant les élections présidentielles
dans
depuis longtemps que cela le
gouvernement français
parce que je suis parlementaire je vote
les lois jeu contrôler l'action du
gouvernement prenne les bonnes mesures
d'urgence bien sûr matière de sécurité
publique
et puis également à court terme et à
moyen terme pour que la situation en
france s'améliore sur le front la
sécurité publique
voilà et là il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire d'accord est ce que vous craignez
puisqu'il ya une question d'actualité
qui se pose que le soccer us qui a été
abattu par la turquie et la frontière
avec la syrie tout à leur remettant en
question justement l'ambition française
d'une vaste coalition contre contre le
groupe etat islamique
bon alors d'abord sur ce sujet
international depuis des mois qu'est ce
que nous réclamons je pense notamment à
bono le maire hockey dont je suis proche
que vous êtes l'âme en soutien
n'attendez pas encore officiellement
candidat bryon pour 2010 seront tous là
mais qu'est ce que nous réclamons nous
réclamons à françois hollande depuis des
mois qu'il prenne l'initiative d'une
coalition internationale
en niveau de l'onu des nations unies
pour qu'il y ait une intervention
unanime au sol en syrie parce qu'on ne
sortira pas de la situation de l'état
islamique sur le territoire si aliens
sur le territoire irakien
sans une seule coalition avec nationale
et donc pour cela ou illusion deux
choses il ne faut pas faire du départ de
bachar el-assad un préalable à tout et
deuxièmement il faut prendre reprendre
langue avec les russes parce que
d'annulations grande nation marc morand
c'est sûr vous pouvez l'écrire aussi que
françois girard depuis des mois on cela
depuis des mois nous savions il y avait
eu beaucoup d'attentes en france il ya
eu dix attentats du mois de janvier il
ya eu d'autres attentats certains ont
été déjoués certains on a pu bénéficier
de chance je pense que l'attentât du
thalys premier ministre nous a dit à de
multiples reprises que nous savions tous
c'est que la france était confrontée à
des attaques terroristes
je suis pas très heureux de constater
tous ces mois perdus pour que le
président de la république change enfin
complètement de pied sur un plan
diplomatique et fasse maintenant de sa
priorité
l'élimination de l'état islamique et pas
une autre la diplomatie c'est de
chercher ses intérêts stratégiques
l'intérêt stratégique de la france salue
attentes selon vous les attentats du 13
novembre
j'espère que par courrier aujourd'hui
mais c'est facile de dire aujourd'hui
oui moi j'entendais encore monsieur le
drian il ya quelques semaines de nous
expliquer que
l'intervention au sol n'était réclamé
par aucun n'est pas qu'elle n'était pas
la solution et qu'il ne fallait pas
retravailler avec les russes tant que la
férule craignait n'était pas réglée et
les militaires les militaires ont
toujours dit qu'ils fer français qui
fait lui aussi une intervention au sol
la cad et le terroir de la part de
cahors à wimille compagne avant sont
aujourd'hui donc le président de la
république après cet attentat qui a
coûté la vie à 130 de nos compatriotes
change d'avis et veut se mobiliser une
grande coalition je m'en réjouis et je
me félicite qu'il soit aujourd'hui aux
états unis et qu'il rencontre l'ensemble
des grands leaders du européens et
occidentaux notamment à l'occasion de la
coop 21 pour que cette grande coalition
mais j'ai vu la première résolution des
nations unies qui unit la semaine
dernière elle ne règne pas encore toutes
les ambiguïtés on voit bien encore jeune
rêveur comme maintenant à feu vert mais
elle n'est pas sous le bon chapitre
en particulier il n'y a pas une large
coalition tous ensemble pour aller sur
le territoire syrien
ra dickey l'état islamique et vous me
parlez la question que vous me posez
c'est par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui absolument avec les russes
la première question j'ai envie de poser
au président la république c est ce que
les russes sont nos alliés j'ai compris
que la marine russe et paul est notre
porte avions charles de gaulle dans la
zone ben écoute et aujourd'hui on a une
question au parlement à l'assemblée
nationale d'un député à l'est
républicain qui est appelé le premier
ministre sur les sanctions à l'endroit
de la russie on peut pas être allié avec
là où il faut considérer qu'elle voulait
lever bien sûr d'accord on ne peut pas y
avait la question portait peut-être plus
sur la turquie est ce qu'il faut
l'incriminé est ce que la turquie
cherche en abattant cet avion russe
aujourd'hui il ya quelques heures
eh bien à torpiller les efforts de paris
notamment pour monter cette grande
alliance entre les occidentaux et la
russie
moi je pense que nous avons le président
landais l'ensemble des dents pays roux a
demandé des comptes très précis à la
turquie sur ses alliés la turquie est
censé être notre allié dans cette
affaire tout le monde est liée contre le
terrorisme aujourd'hui et la prise de
conscience générale et tenter ce que
c'est le gars de là dessus on est
vraiment pourront dépasser la question
précise et par rapide qu'on doit poser
au gouvernement turc en lui demandant de
clarifier tout cela parce que là ce
n'est pas un bon signal de voir l'armée
turque en train d'abattre un avion
puisque là
la turquie nous nous met un coup de
poignard dans le dos comme pour
reprendre l'expression de la douleur
poutine avait raison mais en tout cas ça
départ un comportement qui est très
rassurant
il ya beaucoup de suspicion à l'endroit
de beaucoup pays moi je demande ce que
la france demande à tous les pays à ces
pays du golfe à ces monarchies du golfe
à la turquie de clarifier d'urgence
leurs positions est ce que oui ou non
ils sont à nos côtés pour lutter contre
les thaïs l'année qui est une menace
directe pour nos pays direct pour la
france la france et d'un des principaux
pays visés par les familles nous l'avons
encore revu le 13 novembre dernier et
cette urgence diplomatique elle est
d'importance je suis persuadé que le
président la république le fera alors
clarifier est ce que nous devons
également nous clarifier nos relations
par exemple avec l'arabie saoudite et le
qatar
foehn en vo je pense que s'il y a des
suspicions de comportement de ces
monarchies du golfe à l'endroit de ces
organisations terroristes qu'elles
doivent être levés d'urgence et que la
priorité numéro 1 n'est pas de vendre
des avions à ces pays là on le fait
beaucoup est la priorité numéro un et
leur demander une clarification de leur
position et si leur position continue a
durablement ne pas être clair par
rapport à nos enjeux des intérêts
stratégiques à nous et dont ils auraient
toutes les conséquences
alors on va écouter manuel valls tout à
l'heure lors des questions d'actualité
il a précisé justement ce que françois
hollande cherche à obtenir lors de son
marathon diplomatique cette semaine nous
avons un adversaire cedej et chaque pays
et notamment les pays de la région
doivent venir tous et tous ceux qui sont
concernés par ce conflit que leurs
adversaires c'est d'esch et ne doutez
pas un seul instant que le président
public à cette volonté faire en sorte
que demain
grâce à cette coalition grâce à cette
action grâce à la clarification des
positions de chacun cet ennemi
d'hachette organisation terroriste sera
annulée voilà donc la recherche d'une
coalition concernant une intervention au
sol que vous réclamez thierry solère
boulevard avec la méthode de la part de
quel pays de pays arabes de la région
je pense qu'il faut une seule coalition
internationale il faut donc avoir réglé
son problème avec la russie et arrêter
de faire du départ de bachar el assad
le préalable à tout esprit bachar
el-assad et l'avenir de la syrie bien
sûr que non il faut en parallèle qui est
un travail politique pour préparer
l'après ancienne mais à partir de là il
faut une coalition et tous les experts
militaires internationaux
le dise on arrivera pas on n'éradiquera
pas l'état islamique en syrie et en irak
uniquement par des bombardements et par
une nati une intensification de ces
bombardements
donc alors après est-ce que c'est des
soldats français qui doivent être en
première ligne le réclame non répond
globalement aux anges mais pas entendu
personne avec la nsa depuis des mois
bruno le maire
un cap que la france prenne l'initiative
diplomatique pour l'intervention au sol
d'une coalition internationale les pays
du golfe avec la turquie avec la russie
a coûté beaucoup de temps a été perdu
aujourd'hui la france l'armée française
elle est très très présente sur la bande
sahélienne
je vois bien que ce n'est pas une
solution d'enlever nos soldats là-bas
parce que sinon le terrorisme rose
prospérera à nouveau et une coalition
seniors notamment nous la france 5e
mandat des troupes à sable seulement il
ya quelques minutes barack obama et
françois hollande ont annoncé à
washington qu'il soutenait que la france
et les états unis allaient soutenir
toute intervention au sol se décider à
celle furent très bonne nouvelle mais je
crains parce que je le constate depuis
des mois que la situation des états unis
des rues c'est souvent une situation qui
est très bloquée et ç'a toujours été la
tradition de la france d'être un pays
non-alignés et qui visait à rapprocher
des positions
aujourd'hui j'espère je souhaite que
françois hollande à l'occasion de ses
déplacements et à l'accasion encore une
fois de la cap 21 qui au delà de
l'environnement qui est un sujet très
important à bien sûr se transformer en
grand sommet en lutte anti terroriste
puisse participer à rapprocher ses
positions vous voyez tout bon on
comprend bien que si les états unis et
la russie et l'ensemble des pays du
golfe et la turquie et y ait une grande
puissance européenne ne sont pas tous en
même sens mobilisez pourrait radicaliser
l'état islamique on n'y arrivera pas
alors voilà ce que nous réclamons depuis
la guerre bien vous qu'on ne doit plus
considérés pour l'instant bachar el
assad comme comme le diable si j'entends
bien ce que vous dites je n'ai pas je ne
porte pas un jugement positif sur ma
chère que a néanmoins nous allons
implanter un moment opposition à laurent
fabius qui n'est pas la contacter la
république à aux états unis est la
réponse qui nous a été opposé à chaque
fois c'est que la priorité de la france
c'était d'obtenir le départ de bachar
el-assad
bah oui que quand on tient ses positions
pendant un mois et des mois qu'est ce
qui se passe pas grand chose
d'accord mais aujourd'hui par exemple
les besoins les militaires français vont
se concerter avec avec les russes
cela veut dire que de facto on va aussi
se concerter militairement avec
avec les militaires de bachar el-assad
est de facto un oui j'ai vu comme vous
que quand le président de la république
a décidé l'envoi du porte-avions charles
de gaulle sur zone
c'est la marine russe qui a épaulé ce
déplacement aujourd'hui logistique
donc nous travaillons avec eux c'est
pour ça qu'il est dommage depuis
maintenant plus d'un an d'avoir que nous
cette affaire de du refus de la vente
des deux frégates qui a participé
considérablement à dégrader nos
relations diplomatiques avec la russie
et qu'il est dommage que la france n'est
pas jouer le rôle qui historiquement
encore une fois est le sien c'est-à-dire
de rapprocher les positions
la france n'a jamais été un pays ali
deuxièmement l'iran nous avons réclamé
depuis longtemps également que la
situation évolue et crise dans leur land
aurait pu dès le lendemain de son
élection
travailler à ce sujet il se trouve que
la sphère iranienne a évolué à cause
d'une clé de l'accord nucléaire en iran
est une grande puissance
il faut aujourd'hui très clairement que
nous soyons engagés garrigole que sandra
lacroix je vous pose la question est ce
que françois hollande est à la hauteur
des enjeux aujourd'hui vous répondez oui
mais il ya tout ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers mois la répondu oui je vous ai
répondu qu' il avait la dignité de aux
principales évoquées
je vais prendre les grandes décisions et
d'aujourd'hui d'ouvrir les yeux sur la
nécessité de changer d'alliance
stratégique et de changer de
positionnement politique at il répondu
si vous méprenez pas oui vous me
répondez non il n'est pas la hauteur des
enjeux
bah clair je veux pas rajouter cette
petite phrase c'était la question est ce
qu'il est a ôté à la hauteur ou non des
hors jeu aujourd'hui est ce que vous
voyez
effectivement comme un chef de guerre
mondiale crédible oui ou non non je ne
vous dirai pas ça aussi on voulait pas
d'accord je suis ici je vous réponds que
je vous dis depuis dix mois il n'a pas
fait ce qu'il fallait faire aujourd'hui
il change complètement de ce que vous
dites là on peut le dire d'autres
responsables aussi de votre parti des
républicains à la gpe aussi il a évolué
sur la russie sur je ne reproche jamais
à des gens à d'évoluer
c'est pas des évolutions
c'est un salto arrière qui a été faire
sur beaucoup de sujets et en matière de
politique intérieure et en matière de
politique extérieure en matière de
diplomatie
voilà aujourd'hui on change la france je
m'en réjouis c'est ce que je réclamais
depuis le vainqueur là à z
voilà je voudrais qu'on ne change
vraiment et qu'on en tire toutes les
conséquences
j'ai l'impression qu'on les a pas encore
toutes tirées par don qui peut
comprendre qu'on soit allé avec la
russie sur place dans la collision entre
l'état islamique et que par ailleurs la
france soit à la pointe de sanctions
économiques à travers l'union européenne
va comme un autre club est 2e en matière
de politique intérieure on va sûrement
parler dans le détail absolument tout
cas le coude annonces qui ont été faites
qui font un changement radical par
rapport à ce qui était fait avant les
attentats
et ce souvent des propositions de loi
qui ont été apportés par des députés les
républicains depuis maintenant un an
également réclamée par le pr nisand et à
qui nous avons et à qui le gouvernement
harper veut un refus systématique
non non non c'est très bien on va pas
passer l'émission à dire ce qui est ce
qui est fait aujourd'hui aurait dû être
fait plus tôt parce qu'il va falloir
tenir compte de la nouvelle situation de
la nouvelle donne vous êtes d'accord
enfin la nouvelle diana n'est pas si
nouvelle je vous rappelle qu'il ya eu un
attentat considérable d'années que la
france a connu beaucoup d'attentats
terroristes et que le premier ministre à
de nombreuses reprises nous a dit que la
france était confrontée à une menace
terroriste deux premières amplitude
voilà je vous en rouge se trouve
particulièrement dommage d'annoncer des
mesures au lendemain des attentats qui
auraient pu l'être africain alors la
semaine diplomatique avait commencé avec
la rencontre à l'elysée avec david
cameron en l'écoutant je les soutiens
fermement l'action que le président aux
langes dans l'entreprise pour frapper
l'état islamique en syrie j'ai la ferme
conviction que la grande-bretagne date
en faire de même
voilà donc ils cherchent donc le soutien
de son parlement à londres pourrait
victimes en avoir une action plus
vigoureuse également auprès de ses
alliés
david cameron est ce que vous vous
attendez une
véritable solidarité aujourd'hui des
pays européens pas forcément en terme
d'engagement militaire mais en terme de
soutien financier parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que la france est bien
seul c'est vrai moi je me suis persuadé
que la menace que constitue ce
terrorisme de l'islam radical
l'état islamique et toutes les branches
d'al qaïda en afrique ne vise pas que la
france
elle vise l'ensemble des grands pays
européens et les états unis mais aussi
la france est seul au front nom est la
seule la france par rapport à nos terres
tous les fronts en afrique seuls à
assumer notamment en afrique
l'ensemble des missions et je pense je
souhaite j'espère que ce qui vient de se
passer d'une prise de conscience
générale avec le président de la
république pour le coup et je salue ce
travail là aujourd'hui participe de
faire ouvrir les yeux à ses homologues
européens notamment sur la nécessité de
d'avoir une réaction européenne qui soit
à la hauteur de l'événement vous savez
beaucoup il ya parfois de la défiance
par rapport à l'europe où aller comment
ne peut-il pas comment il pourrait
favoriser ce que je veux dire que quand
je pourrai être autrement quand on voit
sur les sujets financiers la crise
grecque de voir l'europe ne réagir que
au pied du mur quand on voit la crise
des migrants arrivés et quand on voit
l'europe ne commencer à réagir qu'au
pied du mur et que alors que beaucoup de
pays européens les états unis dès le 11
septembre 2001 encore récemment à boston
avec cet attentat à l'occasion du
marathon d'autres pays européens nous la
france à deux reprises majeur dans cette
amie de michael moore est touchée par le
terrorisme de voir que la réponse est si
lente à arriver donc voilà donc on a
raison aujourd'hui par exemple françois
hollande a raison de dire le pacte de
stabilité oui ça attendra d'abord le
pacte de sécurité
c'est aussi une réponse aux tu as i
tunes photos terribles de sa part je
suis persuadé que la france n'arrivera
pas durablement à assumer une mission
régalienne nécessaire qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas suffisamment mise en oeuvre on
ne retrouvant pas une souveraineté
budgétaire et on n'a pas de souveraineté
budgétaire quand on laisse filer les
déficits
deuxièmement je pense que le
les réactions qui nous sont annoncés sur
un plan intérieur ne sont pas du tout à
la hauteur de ce qu'il fallait en faire
notamment sur un plan financier
600 millions de plus dans le budget de
l'état ce n'est pas du tout à la hauteur
d'une priorité nationale je vous met ça
en réverbération de deux trois autres
chiffres
vous savez on a payé un milliard d'euros
à une entreprise ecomouv parce qu'on a
changé de la vie sur l'installation de
tandis qu pour la pour la taxe poids
lourds oui un milliard en moins dans les
caisses de l'état
si la priorité nationale c'est la
sécurité de nos compatriotes 600
millions pour l'année 2016 me paraît pas
être tout à fait à la hauteur
donc je pense que c'est une mauvaise
manière il faut impérativement retrouver
une souveraineté budgétaire diminuer la
voilure là où il ya trop d'état parce
que l'état souvent est une contrainte
pour beaucoup y arriver et on peut y
arriver là avec les forces sécuritaires
mais on peut y arriver si on prend des
vraies décisions et de priorités
budgétaires et deuxièmement je vous en
dirai un mot tout à leur devoir de faire
un grand tour d'horizon de toutes nos
défaillances
alors on en parle et s'en va en parler
là je signale juste avant passé la
deuxième avant de passer à la deuxième
partie qui a eu 11 morts
tout à l'heure vous l'avez entendu dans
l'explosion d'un bus de la sécurité
présidentielle en tunisie 14 morts
maintenant deuxième partie de preuves
par 3 donc tirer solaire avec perrine
tarneaud qui arrive pour vous poser
cette question qui a failli puisque vous
réclamer un audit sur les services de
sécurité et de renseignement vous même
d'ailleurs vous apporter un témoignage
assez éclairant est édifiant sur ce qui
se passe dans certaines prisons par
exemple à nanterre c'était sous l'oeil
des caméras de zone interdite ou ses
directeurs c'est moi ou sa 100e
savary fume fume de la drogue d'ici dans
les couloirs
le land
la legal team chiffres et vous avez des
gens qui t'aiment france télécom de
prendre des téléphones des volets de
logique
toutes sortes de choses beaucoup de
produits alimentaires mais on n'est pas
à l'abri même moment je n'ai en fait
détaché on peut aussi avoir des
vous avez des millions et qui sont venus
série qui vous pouvez savoir à voir des
téléphones portables jesson on en
trouverait bien on
ça s'est un peu pas trop ces analyses et
trois non il faudrait il faudrait qu'on
laisse quasiment à surveiller en
permanence avec bonsoir paris pernod
on vient de voir effectivement cet
extrait de ce reportage qui a été
diffusé dimanche pascal pas tous des
mesures toutes simples à prendre pour
remédier à ces problèmes en prison bien
sûr oui nous les députés on est des
contrôleurs de lieux de privation de
liberté on peut aller en prison quand on
veut moi j'y vais régulièrement au seul
ou avec des collègues si suis retournée
avec david douillet la semaine dernière
qu'est ce que j'ai pu pour aller très
simple très vite trois choses à des
téléphones portables par tous en prison
le directeur m'a avoué on avait trouvé
des téléphones portables dans la cellule
de détenus qui revenait de syrie qui ont
un téléphone portable s'est connecté à
internet ça veut dire que des gens qui
reviennent dessus et qui sont suivis
pour des actes de terrorisme
ils ont un téléphone portable ils sont
contrés thècle istres avec l'extérieur
voir avec l'étranger est-ce qu'ils sont
finalement installés quelque chose comme
la première chose à faire c'est
l'installer des brouilleurs alors à vous
répondre ça coûte cher
oui bien sûr il faut évaluer combien ça
coûte à mon avis ça doit coûter à peu
près une centaine de millions d'euros ou
81 millions d'euros comme un as et de
l'argent mais est-ce que gouverner c'est
pas trouver des solutions et fixer les
priorités
est ce que dans le budget de l'état qui
est absolument considérable
je vous parle même pas du budget des
collectivités locales et tout ce qui va
avec c'est à la hauteur de ne pas
répondre à cette nécessité impérieuse
d'empêcher des détenus qui sont
dangereux de pouvoir communiquer par
internet et par téléphone un résident
ailleurs c'est une priorité d'envoyer
est ce que vous allez faire de ces
constatations vous allez laisser le
gouvernement va saisir le gouvernement
pour tout vous dire dès demain à
l'assemblée nationale à la question des
questions d un moment comme ça madame
taubira le sera
david douillet saisira madame taubira de
me demandes très précises qui auront des
impacts budgétaires
est-ce qu'on ait la capacité d'installer
débrouiller dans les prisons françaises
dans un délai rapide
oui ou non oui on l'est on l'est
techniquement oui on l'est à condition
qu'on ait des marges de manoeuvre et je
reviens à la question vous n'osez on ne
fera pas ça en laissant glisser les
déficits
il faut donc et c'est ça ou vers mais si
on a besoin de personne à la tête de
l'état on doit faire des arbitrages et
moi je pense que il est le temps il est
venu le temps d'arrêter d'avoir un état
en france qui est partout et parce qu'il
s'occupe de tout fait globalement tout
mal
il faut que l'état s'occupe massivement
de ses missions régaliennes la justice
la série est passée aussi qu'elle ait
pas tellement de sens là moi j'ai 44 ans
j'étais un petit 36 mois je ne suis pas
là pour regarder ce qu'a déjà fait les
françois mitterrand jacques chirac
nicolas sarkozy nicolas sarkozy bien sûr
il ya parce que je suis regardé
quel est l'état de la situation de notre
pays le niveau de la fiscalité de mon
pays
est ce qu'on me demande comme effort à
tous les contribuables qui est légitime
et d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'on fait de
leur argent
et moi je vous dis personne n'a par
l'état là dessus à la sécurité publique
dans la rue s'il ne le fait pas bien
personne ne le fera à sa place personne
à part les dames s'occupent des prisons
personne à part l'état ne s'occupe de la
défense nationale et donc il est venu le
temps d'avoir le courage parce que c'est
ça dont il s'agit
le courage politique de prendre des
décisions pour recentrer n'est pas sur
ses missions régaliennes et peut-être le
courage politique aussi de recruter les
baisses d'effectifs en matière de
sécurité du temps de nicolas sarkozy oui
abondamment il ya débat sur le sujet
j'ai encore vu un bon l'autre jour j'ai
chiffres il ya pas tellement de débat ça
sylvain débat sur les chiffres et encore
moins de policiers
depuis cette année qu'il n'y en avait en
2012 et moi je les ai toujours dit je
pense que la rgpp ce n'était pas
obligatoirement sur les sujets régaliens
qui allait le faire mais vous savez on
peut se renvoyer gauche et droite
moi je vous dis pas qu'à droite a tout
bien fait depuis trente ans beaucoup
d'écueils
qu'est ce qui m'importe moi moi je viens
du privé je suis parlementaire g et
élise une élue par les habitants de
boulogne c'est d'apporter des solutions
concrètes à ce qu'attend restons
justement aux solutions concrètes que
vous proposez d'abord à partir du
constat sur certaines failles tu pour ne
pas dire faillite dans le deuxième
deuxième exemple peut-être justement
pour rester en prison sur cette visite
que vous avez effectué avec david
douillet ce qui était marquant c'est que
le directeur de prison ne s'est pas
finalement qui est fiché s dans son
établissement s'est expliqué les choses
très simplement si vous avez quelqu'un
qui fait un braquage un vol à main armée
il est arrêté par la police c'est très
bien on a une police de qualité il va le
placer en détention provisoire
il sera renvoyé devant la justice dans
mx mois pour être jugé pour ce braquage
à mardi s'il se trouve que cette même
personne parallèlement été suivie par la
direction centrale du renseignement
intérieur pour des actes liés à des
réseaux terroristes et qu'il a une fiche
est ce de la plus grande gravité sur ces
sujets là bas quand ils arrivent en
détention le direct la maison d'arrêt ne
le sait pas donc qu'est ce qu'il en fait
ils le placent dans une cellule avec
d'autres détenus et bien donc c'est
comme ça quoi radicalise les autres le
prosélytisme a lieu à cette occasion là
comment c'est possible
en france aujourd'hui que nos différents
services ne communique pas les
informations les uns avec les autres
tout prend un troisième exemple en
dehors de la prison exactement sur le
même sujet on a tous vu un des
terroristes qui s'est fait exploser au
quartier du bataclan on connaît son
passé judiciaire octobre 2012
il est placé sous contrôle judiciaire
suivie par la direction de
l'enseignement intérieur la justice lui
confisque passeports et cartes
d'identité avec une assignation à
résidence
il part en syrie très vite comment il
part en syrie avec un passeport
comment il a le passeport à la justice
lui a retiré c'est ce qu'il a fait il
est allé au commissariat du coin et il
aurait déposé un acte de deux verres ou
de vol de son document d'identité et le
ministère de l'intérieur lui à rémy un
nouveau titre écoutez moi je veux bien
qu'on fasse une surenchère législative
ne comptez pas sur moi pour vous
demander cinquante milliards de mesures
toujours plus sécurité a pour jouer au
plus sécuritaire je crois que les gens
ils sont en droit d'attendre pour mettre
le paquet sur les sujets régaliens et
c'est pour ça que j'ai réclamé qu'on
fasse un audit général de czerny alors
écoutez d'abord ce que dit le
syndicaliste jean françois forget c'est
le président du syndicat pénitentiaire
ufap à propos justement de la
radicalisation dans les prisons il ya
une trentaine de détenus qui apprennent
aujourd'hui sont effectivement à l'écart
des autres et qu ils sont déjà eu entre
eux ce qu'il faudrait éviter faudrait
les séparait déjà entre eux mais sur un
certain nombre de moments de la journée
je pense aux certaines activités et les
parloirs où l'infirmerie bas ils se
retrouvent
avec d'autres co détenus ils peuvent
échanger à travers les cours de
promenade à faire les fenêtres il n'y a
aucune étanchéité on n'est pas dans un
système il faut pour demain si on veut
avancer de façon claire avoir des
établissements à part entière ou en gers
est détenu à part des autres ça c'est
sûr mais aussi à part entre eux de façon
à ce qu'on puisse avoir un travail
efficace tel qu'on le réclame depuis 20
ans oui nous voyons des gens se
radicaliser dans nos prisons dire que
les prisons est le seul endroit où on se
redécale is non dire que c'est un
endroit privilégié de la réalisation oui
voilà pour ce témoignage recueilli par
géraldine beys walo et jordan klein
alors là c'est la radicalisation en
prison c'est quoi la solution selon vous
est ce que c'est d'avoir des
établissements qui accueillent
uniquement des radicaliser d'abord il
faut savoir qui est radicalisée ou pas
et comment se passe cette radicalisation
je vous dis hein déjà les gens qui sont
ultra radicaliser parce qu'ils sont
engagés dans des logiques terroristes en
contact avec la syrie ou qui en
reviennent
cela me semble t'il il faut pas les
mettre en contact avec les autres j'ai
tu suis me suis rendu à fresnes
j'ai vu l'expérimentation qui est mené
par le gouvernement qui a demandé au
gouvernement là bas qu'est ce que ça
veut dire concrètement ça veut dire en
gros on les met l isolement
ils sont tous dans leur celi l'individu
alors c'est sûr qu'ils voient plus grand
monde c'est plutôt bien
est-ce qu'ils vont être d'éradiquer ce
qu'il faut généraliser ces l'annoncent
café manuel valls moi je veux pas vous
donner une réponse de facilité je pense
que c'est très compliqué j'ai étudié à
l'étranger ce que faisaient d'autres
pays en matière de déradicalisation est
très difficile de voir des résultats de
bonne solution la manière pas certain
que ça soit par des petites phrases
qu'on arrivera à trouver des solutions
aisées sur le sujet en tout cas une
nécessité absolue c'est de protéger la
société des gens à l'intérieur et qui
sont dans cette logique aujourd'hui
et deuxièmement quand ils arrivent en
prison ceux qui sont dans une logique de
radicalisation absolue bas qu'ils ne
puissent pas contaminer les autres
et voyez ça serait bien que le ministère
l'intérieur puisse communiquer au
directeur de maison d'arrêt de notre
pays cette décision je ne vois pas au
nom de quel principe ce n'est pas
possible
le cfcm a c'est à dire le conseil
français du culte musulman va mettre en
place une habilitation des imams est ce
que ça va dans le bon sens est-ce qu'on
pourrait s'appuyer par exemple sur eux
concernant justement la déradicalisation
parler c'est un sujet
qui n'est pas nouveau la sarkozie pour
le coup à l'époque quand il était
président de la république avait essayé
de travailler sur ce sujet avec la
création du conseil français du culte
musulman
moi je système c'est la laïcité c'est la
république en république les religions
se soumettent à la république toutes les
religions et pas l inverse
c'est le cas de la religion catholique
ça s'est passé rappelez-vous notre
histoire pas facilement
salomé très longtemps et ça a été très
compliqué c'est le cas avec la religion
juive
voilà le genre juive il est clairement
indiqué qu on se soumet aux lois de
l'état
indépendamment ce qui a marqué dans la
torah et vous avez la prière à la
république française qui est lui dans
les synagogues mais régulièrement mais
il faut que l'islam de france structure
que l'islam en france se structure et
que ce soit en ruine et la destruction
il fallait continuer il fallait
continuer à travailler sur ces sujets là
deuxièmement moi je pense qu'il faut et
maintenant dans les actes et pas dans
les mots expulsés de france tous les
imams salafistes étrangers qui profère
des propos qui ne sont pas compatibles
avec la république
on a tous vu sur une chaîne de
télévision des exemples très précis et
il n'y a pas beaucoup dans beaucoup
d'endroits et ce ne sont pas
malheureusement des cas isolés
donc c'est une urgence à côté pour faire
cela est ce qu'il ya un problème
juridique qui apprennent juridique on
initie au parlement la règle on le règle
et puis ensuite mettons les moyens pour
avoir de l'efficacité et faisons le vous
savez dans toute structure au monde
quand vous avez un accident quand il ya
le paris rio qui fait naufrage en plein
océan atlantique et vous avez plein de
morts vous allez au lendemain on appelle
un audit complet des process de sécurité
à tous les étages
parce que c'est pas possible que ça
recommence eh bien la france elle a été
frappée massivement par le terrorisme
c'était pas la première fois on pouvait
pas dire qu'on ne s'y attendait pas il
eu 130 pas moi je suis parlementaire
j'ai deux fonctions madame à la junte de
fonction soit les droits de vote les
lois et je contrôle l'action du
gouvernement mais moi je demande aux
gouvernements à manuel valls d'instaurer
très rapidement comme ça se passerait
dans toute structure monde
un audit très précis non partisan avec
des députés de différentes formations
politiques et pas judiciaire
c'est un audit précis qu'on balaye tous
les process comment c'est possible le
cas du passeport écoutez c'est
uniquement dans les services
administratifs ou alors également dans
les mers
si on ferme les yeux parfois sur
certains comportements sains déjà une
entreprise aussi par déjà un dans la
cire de l'état on balaye toutes les
grandes procédure et qu'on fasse
remonter leurs difficultés et qu'on les
règle pour demain n'existe plus
franchement c'est pas très compliqué ça
se passe comme ça partout - choses et
l'audit avant d'être parlementaire
croyez-moi quand vous avez une
entreprise très compliqué qui a beaucoup
de problèmes on nous dit on voit la
guerre des problèmes on les règle que
l'état le 6 mai une commission
parlementaire
les gens les gens qui témoignent devant
vous prêtent serment donc ça vous permet
si vous voulez d'encadrer les choses
c'est tout sera bien peu près mais moi
je ne suis pas juge vos biens venus gets
de la commission d'enquêté parlementaire
je suis pas là pour que soit créé un
outil judiciaire je suis là pour concret
à l'audience très technique de contrôle
de l'action du gouvernement qu'on aille
sur place comme on l'a fait avec david
douillet en prison quand vous allez en
prison et on n'est pas le seul à le
faire moi j'y suis allé plus de dix fois
dans des maisons d'arrêt où dans des
prisons ben vous voyez très bien les
dysfonctionnements côté qu'on fasse ça à
plusieurs gauche droite réunies et puis
qu'on liste une quinzaine de choses à
faire en urgence
et puis qu'on les fasse et que ça soit
pas reporté je ne sais pas quelle loi de
programmation ou à quelques disques
gouvernement prenne des mesures
ils ont l'habitude de faire cela c'est
pas quelque chose qui est nouveau pour
eux depuis quelques jours donc ça va pas
les déranger
sur la déchéance de nationalité je vous
propose d'écouter la proposition d'un
sénateur
les républicains gens visés puis je vous
fait réagir après et quand c'est un défi
l'y font ce choix c'est un choix qui est
mûrement délibéré qui n'est pas fait au
doigt mouillé
donc il faut que ça il faut qu'ils
s'attendent à ce qu'ils ne seront pas
les bienvenues mais sans épargner
n'importe quel pays
ceci étant ces apatrides ne sont pas
pour autant je dirais voué à la vindicte
populaire parce que l'article 8 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme fait
en sorte que au niveau je dirais de la
vie privée au niveau d'un certain nombre
de modalités de leur vie ils ne sont pas
je dirais ils sont malgré tout plus
aisément protéger donc c'est quand même
malgré tout relativement doux par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils
sont on voit là jean bizet donc il va
plus loin que la déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux lui
donc on vous l'avez entendu et veut
carrément leur retirer toutes
nationalités donc c'est exactement comme
il le dira en faire des affaires moi je
suis jamais partisan de l'inflation de
mesure où l'inflation législative
croyez-moi si en france toutes les lois
existantes étaient appliquées on n'en
serait pas là
donc l'urgence absolue c'est ce de se
doter de moyens financiers et
organisationnels pour faire que les lois
qui sont votées elles soient réellement
appliquées
ça ira beaucoup mieux alors après est ce
qu'il faut juridiquement trouver de
nouveaux outils juridiques pourquoi pas
en discuter moi j'ai vu la proposition
qui a été fait depuis bien longtemps par
des députés
les républicains je pense notamment à
philippe meunier de déchoir de la
nationalité les binationaux condamné
pour des actes de terrorisme
j'ai encore en souvenir de la réponse
que lui faisait le gouvernement en
disant que c'était scandaleux
je suis très heureux de voir aujourd'hui
au gouvernement arrivait la bouche en
coeur médian qui veulent le faire mais
voyez au fond même cette mesure là c'est
pas l'essentiel
l'essence est un petit peu la surenchère
sécuritaire c'est le risque
oui mais rien de cinq mois je ne suis
pas dans ce registre là moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que la loi de la
république
elles soient pas facultative elle fois
appliquée et aujourd'hui vous avez
énormément de règles qui sont théoriques
mais qui en vrai ne sont pas appliquées
parce que l'état n'a pas les moyens de
se faire respecter
quand vous avez dans cette maison
d'arrêt où et des détenus qui fument du
hachis dans les couloirs avec des
surveillants en face d'eux s'est permis
de fumer de la drogue dans un bâtiment
administratif avec un drapeau français à
l'entrée devant des agents d'état non je
ne le crois pas c'est une façon s'il y
en a mais à force de rogner en
permanence et l'a fait vous pouviez
l'instant au delà de l'état alors je
sois les communes les gens comme les
autres
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire là dessus
bah écoutez il ya eu de toute évidence
et c'est même pas moi qui le dit c'est
malek boutih qui est socialiste
notamment et beaucoup d'autres à gauche
et eu parfois des élus souvent de gauche
qui ont distribué beaucoup d'argent pour
acheter la paire pour parfois aussi des
logiques clientélistes a coûté tout ça
c'est terminé on ne travaille pas et des
associations finalement face à certains
il ya eu des lâchers d'eau radical c'est
ce que vous dites il ya eu des lâchetés
il ya eu du laisser aller il ya eu il ya
eu un éparpillement du jetair il ya eu
une efficacité de l'état qui n'a plus
été au rendez vous et a coûté l'exemple
meilleur que je peux vous donner ce que
vous donnez l'instant bien quelqu'un qui
est poursuivi par la justice pour
terrorisme s'il fait confisquer son
passeport et qui la bouche en coeur vue
au commissariat du coin en disant on me
l'a volé on lui en fait un autre
oui loi avant d'inventer de nouvelles
lois on va peut-être déjà faire
appliquer ce avec vos prérogatives est
ce que vous avez envie d'aller voir ce
qui se passe dans certaines entreprises
oui enfin pour le coup les entreprises
privées on va mal mais je vois dans les
maisons dans les entreprises publiques
portant à la paix à la sncf
l'urgence absolue valérie pécresse elle
a également proposé entre la semaine
dernière qui pourra comprendre à la ratp
et des gens qui soient fichés s pour des
problèmes de terrorisme parce qu'une
fiche s et des gens qui sont sur des
fiches c'est ce qu'on a pas laissé
tomber un peu certains pans de la
laïcité française
on a une façon générale dans la société
française il ya ce cas pas une
coresponsabilité peut-être des
politiques de ces grandes entreprises
publiques
enfin la laïcité encore une fois le
principe en permettant d'ouvrir délaissé
à laisser des gens alors qu'il ya une
loi qui interdit le port de la burqa en
france être habillée comme ça dans la
rue et moi j'ai des collègues qui m'ont
expliqué que en gros il ya vu des
consignes qui avait été donné dans
beaucoup de départements de ne pas
interpeller des gens qui t'aiment jeu
voile intégral parce qu'il fait leur la
paix non pardon la règle de droit actuel
en france elle doit être appliquée alors
il n'y a pas le choix et c'est le jeu et
ceux qui ne veulent pas se soumettre aux
lois de la république ils ont rien à
faire sur l'espace public français
c'est ça la vérité donc vous êtes
d'accord avec emmanuel macron quand il
dit que finalement la responsabilité de
la france c'est d'avoir donné un terreau
favorable à la radicalisation
oui à sagem pas non plus prendre le
sujet par là parce que souvent à gauche
autant emmanuel macron a des fois des
pauvres parfois des propositions
intéressantes notamment dans la sphère
économique moi je participais de ce
qu'ils considéraient que la loi macron
c'était une petite avancée est bon on
n'a pas eu l'occasion de voter pour ou
contre 1 parce que vous ne m'en a pas de
majorité
autant ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
culture de l'excusé moi je veux pas
laisser proliférer cette culture de
l'excusé qui pourrait justifier quoi que
ce soit la france est pas non plus un
pays qui n'est pas accueillants avec
tout le monde c'est un pays qui même
quand vous n'avez pas de revenus et vous
n'avez pas de travail vous donne des
allocations c'est un pays qui vous donne
la sécurité sociale même quand vous
n'avez pas de revenus et qui vous
garantit d'être soigné à l'hôpital quand
vous serez malade c'est un pays qui même
quand vos parents n'ont pas d'argent
vous offre la capacité à l'école
l'université et d'avoir une formation
qui vous permet de vous elle n'a pas
beaucoup des pays au monde qui font
autant pour tout le monde donc
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
en disant qu'on a créé un terreau
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est surtout
des lâchetés de la part des gouvernants
et un laisser aller général et non
maîtrise de nos finances publiques et de
nos priorités qui a fait qu'on en arrive
là plutôt que notre modèle d'accueil qui
au contraire est très généreux mais le
gardien question il ya une petite
nostalgie en ce moment autour du service
national pour ou contre son retour
alors si on parle du service national
dans la partie militaire je suis contre
j'aimerais bien dans un monde absolu
mais la vérité c'est qu'on a supprimé en
1995 à peu près je crois de mémoire le
service nationale et qu'on n'a pas les
militaires pour l'encadrer et on n'a
plus les bases pour l'accueillir
donc ça me paraît assez démagogique
après concret à un service un sens à nos
amis grecs quand on vous entend voilà je
pense que c'est pas réaliste en tout cas
de faire cela par contre d'avoir un
service civique je vous rappelle qu'il
existe déjà on le généraliste plus oui
vous savez voilà moi droits et devoirs
ça me paraît bien s'il viendra plus
aussi de voir les gens merci ferrin
nadège plus jack de la fp arrive
maintenant thierry solère avec cette
question pourquoi votre party les
républicains semblent à la peine à moins
de deux semaines donc maintenant des
élections régionales le paysage
politique et électoral bien sûr change
change forcément dans un état dans un
pays en état d'urgence écoutons ce qu'en
dit le politologue pascal perrineau
alors le république il est républicain
l'associer à l'idée au modem sont pris
un peu dans un étau ils ont à la fois un
front national qui sur leur droite a
retrouvé une certaine dynamique et sur
la gauche il avait un parti socialiste
qui était en train de se déliter qui
semble stopper ou freiner son délitement
donc l'espace qui de progression qui
était le leur et plus compter
qu'auparavant cela n'empêchera pas
certainement ses forces dans de
nombreuses régions d'emporter l'exécutif
mais le combat sera plus difficile
particulièrement au second tour
voilà donc un état des lieux politique
pascal perrineau analyse recueillis à
quelques instants par géraldine beys au
botswana déjà qu'un salaire entendu
monsieur perrineau donc les républicains
sont pris dans un étau on sait ce qu'il
nous dit vous avez vous dit vous même
tout à l'heure que le président de la
république et le gouvernement à les
piocher à droite pour présenter leurs
mesures pour lutter contre
risme alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
vous êtes vous coupent l'herbe sous le
pied vous êtes vous êtes à la peine
c'était vous êtes des avantages et là
j'ai l'impression de pas vieillir parce
que à chaque élection depuis trois ans
en fin de période préélectorale avant
les municipales avant les
départementales et maintenant avant les
régionales
pour des raisons diverses celle là et
dans un contexte beaucoup plus triste
bien sûr on vient m'expliquer ça avant
les départementales
je viens de poser ces questions-là avant
les départementales en début d'année on
expliquait que c'était terrible que
françois hollande allait un peu mieux
que le front national explorer était
d'ailleurs on a laissé le député excusez
moi et là on a entendu monsieur
perrineau qui évoque un analyste
politique nous expliquer les
républicains sont pris dans un étau et
c'est vrai on a vu quand même le
président de la république et le premier
ministre nous annoncer des mesures que
dont parle monsieur sarkozy parle depuis
un an
vous et moi je ne crois pas que les
hommes politiques soient lynch et quand
il son pouvoir sur leurs discours mais
sur les actes et on fera le bilan de la
politique du gouvernement et du
président de la république à la fin de
son quinquennat en matière d'emploi en
matière d'économie et en matière d'état
régalien et on verra si la situation
était mieux gérer à la fin du
quinquennat françois alors qu'au début
et je ne crois pas qu'aujourd'hui la
france soit sur un plan de l'emploi sur
l'économie ou sur un plan de la sécurité
publique dans un meilleur état qu'il ne
l'était il a pris entre deux feux
quand même là de la perspective des
régionales vous parlez des questions
dans la perspective des régionales ils
assurent pas comme et ou sinon je lui
racontais vous avez donc la gauche qui
reprend un petit peu de bol de poil de
la bête on voit dans l'est dans les
sondages et puis et puis il ya le front
national qui monte alors à bâtir nouveau
comment mieux situer l'arve en matière
de sondages je sais pas si on est pris
en étau mais si vous vous intéressez aux
frais je les lis je vous avoue je les
lis comme vous celui d'ile-de-france doc
bartolone au même niveau que le front
national à 22 et valérie on parle de la
région paca le candidat de socialistes
qui représente le gouvernement est
crédité de 16% d'intentions de vote
donc vous voyez les taux en tout cas
attendu
mais le candidat le camp républicain le
cantique à le côté gauche de l'étau ne
prend pas beaucoup d'épaisseurs ces
temps ci à peu près dans toutes les
régions
après le front national est crédité de
l'attention doit très importante dont
nombreuses régions notamment au nord et
au sud oui parce que la politique du
gouvernement depuis trois ans c'est un
tract ambulants pour le front national
ces hausses d'impôts massives sur la
classe moyenne des gens qui gagnent 2000
2500 euros par mois et on leur en quoi
comme service public derrière on leur
offre de la sécurité publique en bas de
la rue et dans les transports
non on leur offre une entreprise monde
économique compétitif il y aura des
entreprises qui pourront être
compétitive et donc les embauches et non
plus alors les gens se désespère et que
la participation annoncée aux élections
est toujours basse et le vol pour les
extrêmes ne fait que monter la seule
chose qui nourrit le front national
c'est l'absence de résultats des
gouvernants voilà ce que je dis non mais
là on parle quand même bien de la
nouvelle donne créée bien sûr par les
attentats et la politique le virage
sécuritaire bon à côté si on parle juste
de son âge régionaux moi je vous dis par
exemple je suis tête de liste dans le
département des hauts-de-seine engagé
auprès de la mairie pécresse elle se
prépare à cette élection depuis
longtemps ils y apportent des réponses
précises pour qu'enfin on arrête de
dilapider de l'argent dans tous les sens
on se concentre sur les missions
régaliennes de la région des transports
en commun rénové où on sentira en
sécurité des lycées rénové où nos gamins
se sont seront à la sécurité aux abords
et à développement économique pour qu'on
arrête de chasser les entreprises à
chaque fois qu'ils préfèrent aller dans
d'autres pays que chez nous voilà les
trois priorités bas côté qu'est ce que
je vois je vois que ça fait 17 ans que
les socialistes gèrent cette région
qu'ils ont eue le fait du clientélisme
comme jamais qu'ils ont continué à
construire des logements sociaux
allaient socialiste en ile de france
notamment je pense en seine saint denis
dans dix villes où vous allez m'aider à
70%
certaines fabriquer des ghettos eh bien
ils sont aujourd'hui récusé et vous en
arrivez à un niveau où le candidat
socialiste claude bartolone
il est crédité d'à peine du même score
dans notre sondage du sauvage qui vient
de sortir que le front national
oui la seule alternative possible qu'on
doit pas garder même sondage parce que
moi j'avais plusieurs sondages ou été
réédité de 50% au deuxième tour comme
madame pécresse ça c'est des sondages de
ces anciens depuis il est l'écart se
creuse et vous avez un sondage où la
première de chine
il en garde enfin je mets toujours pas
un sondage tu peux peut-être vous plaire
cbv à pour le point qui vient de sortir
je crois aujourd'hui 17 points au plus
pour monsieur hollande les français donc
le créditent d'une bonne gestion de la
crise des événements et aussi des bons
points pour nicolas sarkozy qui
rassemble sa famille à droite
est-ce que c'est aussi votre sentiment
non mais c'est légitime et logique on
avait déjà vu ça malheureusement au
lendemain des attentats de charge et que
le président de la république et une
cote de confiance et le baudet pignon
qui a incroyablement est historiquement
basses je crois qu'il est arrivé au
niveau le plus bas qu'un président de la
vème république a pu avoir et un regard
de mais là ils vont arriver au plus
grand jamais connu oui voilà il partait
de très très bas alors voilà donc c'est
assez légitime mois les sondages je
voulais un commenté ça avec vous n'avez
spisak mais au fond c'est pas ça qui
m'importe est pardon je termine là
dessus ce qu'ils voudront les gens me
semble-t-il ans aux élections régionales
c'est d'avoir à la tête de la région des
gens car est de dilapider l'argent on
sait pas où ça va et qui leur rendent
qui leur rendent dans des transports
dans des lycées et de développement
économiques stévia les trois grandes
compétences de la région de qualité et
ça nous on a des candidats de bon niveau
et valérie pécresse notamment en
ile-de-france et très préparés à cela au
lendemain des régionales on entrera dans
une nouvelle séquence la présidentielle
de 2017 me semble-t-il les français
chercheront à la tête de l'état celui ou
celle qui incarnera des solutions
concrètes crédible pour que l'économie
aille mieux et surtout que la sécurité
publique soit assurée pas dans des
grands discours mais dans les actes
alors avant de parler de 17 on va parler
de ce qui se passe maintenant on a bien
eu un temps là l'impression en vous
écoutant depuis tout à l'heure de début
d'émission que comme les républicains
sont très embêtés entre le devoir
d'unité nationale et puis votre rôle
d'opposant vous ne l'avez dit à
plusieurs reprises ce qui était que
votre rôle d'opposant alors est-ce que
vous pensez que les républicains
notamment le président des républicains
à monsieur nicolas sarkozy vous avez
bien placé le curseur entre ces deux
pôles et tout le monde sait que c'est
pas évident pour vous comment comment
vous le ressentez bon c'est très
difficile d'en lendemain d'attentats le
rôle d'opposant ce n'est pas quelque
chose que les gens attendent aujourd'hui
ils attendent quoi il attend qu'on
continue d'arrêter à ceux qui ont commis
ces attentats terroristes étaient
toujours pas le cas il reste des gens on
les poursuit jusqu'en belgique
donc il ya une peur et c'est l'exécutif
le gouvernement qui est à la manoeuvre
sur ce sujet après peut-être te dire que
on va arrêter de parler des sondages
mais peut-être que l'opinion une partie
de l'opinion publique française vous
rapproche un ton trop virulent mais en
venir alors que la semaine dernière à
l'assemblée nationale la séance a été
très houleuse et on a beaucoup dit on a
beaucoup entendu on a beaucoup lu que
c'était de la faute des députés
républicains
qu'est-ce qu'il en avait sept députés
républicains qui n'ont pas été pris une
fois à crier dans une ici que je n'aime
pas un mode de fonctionnement basé à
l'assemblée nationale je vous dis une
quinzaine de députés à gauche une
quinzaine de députés à droite qui ont
comme mode d'expression le hurlement
régulièrement et pas que dans ces
moments là le problème c'est que quand
on est dans ces moments là ce n'est plus
étonnant c'est pitoyable et on a été
dans boel dire en direct
bon écoute et voilà depuis le calme est
revenu et moi ce que j'attends de ma
famille politique et elle le fait vous
savez le matin même on avait eu nicolas
sarkozy qui était venue à la réunion de
groupe
devant les parlementaires il a vu un
discours très précis très apaisé il nous
avait dit au départ en pour
l'intervention que concernant les
régionales ça c'est pas le sujet
personne ne sait rien on verra bien que
les français nous regarder tous et que
les français dans ces moments-là il a
gardé les hommes politiques pour essayer
de savoir qui était crédible pour
apporter des réponses concrètes discours
apaisé de monsieur sarkozy pendant la
réunion de groupe
qu'est ce qui s'est passé l'après midi
il s'est passé que je vous dis une
dizaine de personnes qui à gauche comme
à droite crie beaucoup
il va s'en excuser seul à s'en excuser
leur comportement qui qui était en
colère qui était en colère quand vous
êtes un député qui a un son pas en
colère c'est une leçon en permanence qui
hic est en colère qui quand vous être
présenté ce qui n'est pas mon cas qui a
déposé une proposition de loi à de
nombreuses reprises pour lutter
efficacement contre le terrorisme
participer en tout cas et convoque qu'on
vous dit c'est la surenchère qu'on vous
dit que vous courrez derrière le front
national et que vous voyez le chef de
l'état le premier ministre
arrivé la bouche en coeur au lendemain
de 130 morts en reprenant exactement mot
pour mot aux propositions
ya konan bédié à ce propos de terrorisme
le l'ancien policier chef de la police
monsieur squarcini a fait une
il a fait une interview à valeurs
actuelles ces seules où il dit qu' il y
a deux ans il était approché par les
syriens qui ont dit voilà on est prêt à
vous donner des listes de terroristes de
français qui viennent en syrie mais
évidemment en échange il faut un petit
peu de coopération avec nous et
paraît-il que le gouvernement le nôtre
aurait refusé est ce que vous êtes au
courant de cette histoire j'ai bien sûr
lui c'est l'information est d'ailleurs
j'attends des explications très claires
parce qu'il ya deux solutions soit
bernard qu'on se croise in i qui était
le patron du renseignement intérieur
française par n'importe qui à l'époque
des faits dit vrai ça veut dire que les
autorités syriennes et les services de
renseignements syriens ont proposé à la
france une liste de france est engagée
dans des activités terroristes et on
l'aurait refusée si c'est ça c'est d'une
extrême gravité
ou bien c'est faux il ya des poursuites
qui doivent être engagés à l'endroit de
ce soir ci nie pas ce qu'on appellera
dire des choses de cette nature
donc moi j'attends du gouvernement et de
manuel valls qui nous disent exactement
la vérité qu'il en tire toutes les
conséquences
bon alors on va parler maintenant des
régionales on en a parlé on a vu qu'il y
avait une incidence de ces événements
sur les régionales mais vous espérez
quand même avoir beaucoup de régions
m'écouter audabran toutes les régions
sont gouvernés par la gauche
qu'est ce que je constate je constate
qu'il ya un élan quand même énormément
de région aujourd'hui je constate aussi
parce que j'oublie les sondages que le
front national notamment au nord et au
sud de la france est très élevé je pense
que la seule alternative dans le coup je
populaire que vous je sais pas si ça
veut dire que ça je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens exaspérés et que le
front national c'est bien ramener à lui
les électeurs exaspérés
maintenant que les électeurs attendent
des réponses très concrètes et des
changements sur un plan économique et
sur le plan de la sécurité
je ne suis pas certain que ce soit la
meilleure solution je pense que la seule
alternative possible c'est les
républicains et que ça marchera à une
seule condition c'est que nous nous
proposions des solutions crédibles à des
facilités et c'est ce que nous faisons
nombreuses régions et moi je suis
persuadé valérie pécresse ras el juli de
franges mercedes bruno retailleau
reprendre à la gauche la région des pays
de la loire
je suis persuadé qu hervé morin
reprendre
normandie nous susurre que vous avez des
doutes tout le monde le voit bien c'est
dans la région nord pas de calais
picardie et dans la région paca que la
situation est bien sûr très tendue mais
je pense que sinon les républicains en
large victoire à l'occasion de ces
élections régionales de nom après les
régionales qu'est ce qui va se passer
les primaires un deck les régionales
vont être terminées vous avez tous vous
mettre sur la primaire comment est-ce
que ça se passe chez vous écoutez ça se
passe bien on s'est engagé dans cette
affaire qui est nouvelle pour nous elle
a pris mais pourquoi parce que tout le
monde comprend bien vous pensez avoir
dit dans la presse consacre un jour -
des dents que deux candidats sur
l'organisation par exemple durs haute
vallée juste mon raisonnement mais je
rappelle que vous êtes chargé de
l'organisation de cette primaire où en
êtes vous alors on en n'est qu'un
d'abord pourquoi on a fait ça parce
qu'on ne peut pas avoir deux candidats
de la droite et du centre candidats pour
des temps de la présidentielle tout le
monde le comprend bien
et donc c'est le seul moyen bien sûr
c'est nouveau pour nous bien sûr c'est
qu'il est plein questionnement
mais le parti au travail oui avant de
venir à cette émission j'étais encore
avec l'ensemble des membres du comité
d'organisation
on se réunit toutes ses soirées à l'idée
des nouvelles toutes fraîches très en
avance écoutez la haute autorité est
maintenant complétée elle et elle s'est
engagée sur un plan financier le parti
politique et république a fait un gros
travail de restructuration et a dans son
budget 2000 16 5 millions d'euros pour
organiser cette primaire donc le
financement de la primaire est bouclé et
n'est en train de finir de boucler la
nomination pas très sympathique sur ce
financement de la primaire à savoir que
chez pardon les juppéiste on s'énerve
beaucoup parce que euh si j'ai bien
compris veulent une structure externe au
parti pour le financement et puis le
sarkozysme ne veulent pas vous pouvez
nous expliquer un petit peu ce qui se
passe ça tire vraiment j'ai vraiment des
gros tiraillements chez ou est ce que
c'est vrai ou est ce qu'on nous raconte
des bêtises à je pense que ça peut
arriver qu'on vous raconte des bêtises
parce que sincèrement ça se passe bien
ça va aussi parce qu'on s'entend bien
les uns les autres moi je m'entends très
bien avec brice hortefeux avec edouard
philippe qui travaillait bien juppé et
on se parle en franchise
aujourd'hui on s'est engagé dans cette
affaire on a listé les endroits où il y
aura des bureaux de vote
on a les structures juridiques ou son
président du bureau de vote soit
organisé pour les français de l'étranger
ça se passera par un vote par internet
et par le financement moi je veux saluer
le travail de daniel fasquelle qui le
trésor des républicains puisque dans le
budget 2016 du parti il ya 5 millions
qui ont été votés il ya mis
on conseille à dix quinze jours
maintenant au conseil national des
républicains dans le deal extreme être
externalisées pour la haute autorité
dans tout le monde est d'accord sur le
sujet est ce que vous avez réussi à
rassurer les sarkozystes qui trouvaient
que le nombre de bureaux de vote et
10000 était excessif et ingérable non
franchement julie ça aussi mais je n'ai
pas entendu ça chez un client ni
déclaration publique à demain il ya dans
le sud de la france et dans l'est
quelques maires présidents de
départements qui considèrent qu'il ya
trop de bureaux de vote dans l'ouest et
pas assez dans l'est aimé briller tout
ça c'est des détails pardon c'est
presque de parler tout ça aujourd'hui
au fond on est engagé dans cette logique
de primaire tout le monde voit bien
qu'on pourra pas faire autre chose que
les affaires et vraiment on y va et on
organisera dans un an pile 20 novembre
il lâche primaire qui permettra à toute
personne qui se revendiquent des valeurs
de la droite et du centre de venir voter
pas uniquement des adhérentes partis
politiques
dernière question vous soutenez toujours
monsieur bruno le maire écoutez c'est
faut être fort moi je suis engagé auprès
de bruno ça se passe très bien et on est
dans un comité d'organisation ou et
leurs films soutien juppé ou d'occasion
on verra bien qui sera candidat la fin
et surtout on soutiendra tous le
vainqueur de la primaire
on suivra tout cela merci beaucoup
siaved merci tirées ces dernières heures
étaient avec nous ce soir mais on sera
tous et à bientôt